الى التطورات الميداليه في اوكرانيا وفي
تفاصيل العمليات العسكريه نبدا بالهجمات
الصاروخيه الروسيه اذ قالت قياده الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان روسيا اطلقت نحو 43 صاروخا
اسقطت منها سته وثلاثين وقد استهدف 20
صاروخا العاصمه عن اصابه اشخاص
وتضرر مباني ومنشات مختلفه اضافه الى
استهداف مقاطعه شير كاسي جنوبيه ما اسفر
عن اضافه او عن اصابه عده اشخاص في فندق
في غربي اوكرانيا تعرضت مقاطعه لهجوم
مشابه فاصيبت منشاه للطاقه ما ادى الى
القطاع التيار الكهربائي عن نحو 400 مدينه
وقريه بينها مناطق في مقاطعه كياف اما في
الفيف غربا فسقط صاروخان على منطقه دوره
بيتش ما ادى الى تدمير منشاه صناعيه ومخزن
كما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه توجيه
ضربه للقوات الرو سيه في مطار ساكيا
العسكري في شبه جزيره القرم هذا واضافت ان
الهجوم كان مشتركا بين سلاح البحريه وقوات
الامن وما اسفر الى عن تدمير اثنتي عشره
طائره روسيه وفقا لوزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه
ماذا عن الروايه الروسيه فقد اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع ان القوات الروسيه دمرت 19 طائره
مسيره اوكرانيه فوق شبه جزيره القرم بينما
اعلنت سلطات القرم المواليه لروسيا انها
اعترضت كل الصواريخ التي حاولت استهداف
قاعده جويه في القرم كما قالت الدفاع
الروسيه ان قوتها اسقطت ثلاث طائرات مسيره
فوق مقاطعات كورسكيه